so the nominees for Best Performance by
an actress in a leading role are Joan
Allen in the contender Juliette Binoche
in sha allah Ellen Burstyn in Requiem
children Laura Linney when you can count
on me
Julie Raghava
and the Oscar goes to Julia Roberts
Roberts first Academy Award
and your third nomination she was
nominated in this category for pretty
woman and for her supporting role and
Steel Magnolias
oh thank you thank you ever so much
I'm uh I'm so happy thank you I I uh I
have a television so I'm going to spend
some time here to tell you some things
and and and sir you're doing a great job
if you're so quick with that stick so
why don't you sit because I may never be
here again
um I would like to start with telling
you all how amazing the experience of
feeling The Sisterhood of being included
in a group with Joan Allen and Juliette
Binoche and Laura Linney and Ellen
Burstyn for these last weeks has been it
just felt like such a triumph to me to
be in that list um my name starts with R
so I'm always last but I still love the
list uh but um I can't believe this is
this is some is quite pretty um I I want
to acknowledge so many people that made
Erin Brokovich Erin Brockovich but let
me make my dress pretty uh
Universal everybody Universal Kevin
mature and and Stacey Snider and Stacey
sheer and I can't believe I'm
remembering Rudy's name um
Jersey films Danny DeVito hmm um and
everybody over there everyone I've ever
met in my life um uh this movie was
sinfully fun to make and Albert Finney
is my friend and my pleasure to act with
and Aaron Eckhart and Scottie and German
and Brittany and Ashley all the
wonderful actors that played my children
and marg Helgenberger and turned that
clock off it's making me nervous
greg jacobs everybody on our crew that
were so great and oh well just a few
other people and but really the main
person well Richard LaGravenese and
Susannah grant who wrote such a nice
script um Steven Soderbergh hi there you
are um you truly just made me want to be
the best actor that I suppose I never
knew I could be or aspire to and I made
every attempt stick man I see you so I
thank you for really making me feel so
good up here
yeah anyway I started working for him
again in two days so I can get to you
later but Benjamin Bratt my sister Lisa
my brother-in-law Tony Elaine goldsmith
Thomas who's been my agent since God was
a boy
Jeff Berg my mom and just Francis and
Marcus and Mike and everybody who's
watching home Kelli Emma everybody I
love the world I'm so happy thank you